so i'll be talking about uh
joint work with jamie morgenstern who's
making a cameo actually today at the
conference
she did this when she was visiting at
stanford now she's a postdoc at pen
uh so the workshop is called complexity
and simplicity and economics and a lot
of this week
we're exploring that theme in the
context of mechanism design
so what makes a mechanism complex
or simple anyways so there's not a
unique answer to this question
but let me open with a couple of
examples which sort of
capture the you know which illustrate
the kind of simplicity that i want to
capture
so in a 2009 paper with jason hartline
we called it simple versus optimal
mechanisms
we studied domains which you know are
squarely in the realm of meyerson's
theory so we knew what the optimal
mechanism was these are single parameter
settings
independent private values so we know
the revenue maximizing mechanism is just
a virtual welfare maximizer
so our motivation for this paper is we
said well you know you look around in
the world
and so think about the non-symmetric
case where bidders have independent but
not identical evaluations
the virtual welfare maximizers you get
in those settings they don't really
resemble
auction formats that we see out there in
the real world so we were wondering
could we have a more
sort of realistic simple if you will
auction format
that uh had a performance guarantee that
was almost as good as the theoretically
optimal
myosin mechanism and most of our results
focus on the case of the vcg mechanism
such as welfare maximization
but coupled with reserve prices and
monopoly reserve prices are the natural
ones to use
and we identify conditions under which
in fact vcg with monopoly reserves is a
good approximation of the optimal
mechanism so for example metroid
feasibility constraints regular
evaluation distributions
arbitrary downward closed environments
mhr distributions
uh and things like that okay so this was
sort of what we held up as a simple
versus optimal result
nowhere in this paper do we say what we
mean by a simple mechanism
we leave it as sort of uh subjective or
or self-evident
uh you know adjective and uh you know
had you pressed me at the time
you know what am i trying to get at why
how do i justify that the mechanism on
the left is simpler than the one on the
right
what i would have said was well you know
imagine you range over all possible
choices of the valuation distributions
for the bidders f1 through fn what class
of mechanisms do you get on the left
ranging overall distributions well you
just get the vcg mechanism with all
possible choices of bitter specific
reserves
okay so some in some sense n degrees of
freedom and then mechanism design space
where n is the number of bitters
on the other hand if you do the same
thought experiment on the right hand
side now when you range over
distributions you range over all
possible
virtual valuation functions for the
bidders which feels like a much larger
maybe even infinite number of degrees of
freedom
so that's that's not a formal statement
but that's the intuition i would have
said
uh back in 2009 so last five years
we've seen a lot of really cool simple
versus optimal
approximation results uh so one example
it's a justly celebrated result from
last year baba yafi malika lucian
weinberg
this is now a multi-parameter setting so
they were thinking about one buyer where
you have k items
added evaluations with independent
valuations across the items
and this is you know trying to figure
out the optimal mechanism revenue
optimal mechanism in this setting is
very hard in fact that problems
occupying
many of the greatest minds in agt as we
speak so bobby if at all
we're saying well you know if we relax
to approximation you know can we get
a practical sort of simple auction
format with a performance guarantee
and they show that the answer is yes
okay so they said well
for any distribution independent
distributions over the over the items
either the mechanism that just always
sells all items together the grand
bundle
and of course if you're going to do that
you may as well monopoly price the grand
bundle
or if that doesn't work then you can
just sell the items separately
and again if you're doing that you may
as well use monopoly reserves
right so those are the if you for every
distribution the better of those two
will be a constant factor
and again to me this feels like you know
maybe okay maybe like k plus two degrees
of freedom
and the mechanism space on the left
right so you have a choice of monopoly
reserve for each of the item
you have a choice of the monopoly
reserve for the grand bundle and then
maybe you have like an extra bit
about whether you sell items separately
or sell the grand bundle okay so again
like ballpark
k degrees of freedom and we heard
earlier this week andy yao's very
elegant extension of the multi-multiple
buyer case
rubinstein and weinberg have an
extension the sub additive valuations
so these are i'm holding up as sort of
uh
illustrative simple mechanisms again
currently undefined
so the goal for today is to propose a
rigorous a quantitative
definition of the simplicity or the
complexity of a mechanism rather
of a family of mechanisms now why do i
want to do this
well several reasons one reason is just
so that we know what we're talking about
so
you know we can actually say something's
a simple mechanism and mean something
mathematical
but once you have a formal definition it
opens up
research directions which otherwise
wouldn't really be well defined
so for example if you have a you know we
know how to measure near optimality
right we do that with performance
guarantees approximation ratios
if we also have a way to measure
simplicity or complexity we can now
treat the mechanism design
goal of wanting simple mechanisms with
good guarantees as a bona fide buy
criteria optimization problem right so
you can ask about
for a given simplicity budget what kind
of approximation guarantee can you
attain or for a given approximation a
one minus epsilon approximation for
example
what kind of complexity is necessary in
your mechanism to achieve that kind of
revenue guarantee
again that doesn't you can't even pose
those questions without some kind of
definition
and then the other thing you might hope
for and this will indeed be the case
today is that if you had a good
definition of a simple mechanism
maybe they would have extra desirable
properties for free okay so simplicity
would imply some other
good thing and for today the good thing
you're going to get is you're going to
get
good results for learning so if a family
of mechanisms is simple
you'll be able to learn the best
mechanism from that class with respect
to an unknown distribution
with polynomial sample complexity
all right so before i dig into more of
the details let me just
sort of position this work with respect
to the literature and even other things
you've seen earlier this week
so you know mechanisms can be simple in
many senses and you know all but one of
those senses i won't be discussing today
uh so for example something we heard a
lot about on tuesday is being simple to
play
and so you know the good news is i'll
just be thinking about dominant strategy
and seneca compatible mechanisms so just
you know our boring old
d6 friends uh i won't be making any
distinction between
say you know mechanisms that are even
even better for the players to play like
the deferred acceptance options that
paul and elia talked about
or the obviously strategy proof
mechanisms that lee discussed so
i'm making no differences between
different kinds of uh diesel mechanisms
um so a second thing so for the
motivating applications as you saw the
type spaces are all pretty small
so direct revelation mechanisms is sort
of a reasonable thing to do
if you're thinking about something like
full-blown combinatorial options
auctions
you don't you don't want to think about
direct revolution mechanisms you really
need a message space for a bid space
which is smaller than the type space
and so there there's a really
interesting notion of simplicity where
you measure how big the type space is or
how many actions are available to
players
and you can actually sort of
characterize efficiency guarantees as a
function of that notion of simplicity
again not talking about it
probably the historically earliest
attempt by computer scientists
to impose some kind of simplicity
constraint the mechanism design was just
you know let's at least force them to
run in polynomial time or polynomial
communication
okay so that's the field of aggregate
mechanism design it's been hugely
successful
not though super relevant actually for
the motivating examples
i gave you at the beginning right so
like the very first example we were
comparing vcg with monopoly reserves
versus a virtual welfare maximizer with
respect to computational complexity
those are polynomial reducible problems
get those have exactly the same
complexity so
this won't let me differentiate between
the different mechanisms and my
motivating examples at least not not in
the first one certainly not in single
parameter settings
let me give a quick shout out to a
couple other pieces of related work that
are very
kind of similar in spirit to what i'm
talking about first notion
menu complexity by sergio and noam they
introduced this a couple years ago it's
a very nice definition let's look at a
lot of interesting work
this has it shares really the same goals
i had a couple slides ago so you wanted
to have a concrete measure
of the complexity of the mechanism so
that you could ask about revenue
complexity trade-offs and they do that
they give a precise definition
what's the definition well you know
think about a player
so by the taxation principle you know
once you fix everybody else's reports
really what a player faces is a menu of
allocation price pairs and it can pick
its
favorite one in effect so that's one way
to think about strategy proof mechanisms
so the menu complexity just says how
many different options might a player
have
in the worst case okay so that's the
menu complexity
and uh so i guess you know again it's
just not quite a good fit for for the
examples i want to discuss today
basically because you know while maybe
menu complexity is a sufficient
condition
for a mechanism to be regarded as
intuitively simple it's not a necessary
condition
so for example as soon as you choose a
price at random
you have infinite menu complexity okay
secondly
think about like the you know single buy
or multiple item setting
think about selling items separately how
many different outcomes can the bidder
require for itself
well i can pick any bundle it wants
right if the items are sold separately
you just
pick them so there's two to the k okay
so already selling items separately
gives you exponential
menu complexity they do propose a fix
for this additive menu complexity but
i'm looking for something kind of a
little different
all right second paper uh which is many
years ahead of its time
it's entitled mechanism design via
machine learning balkan blum
heartland and mansur so they also
uh propose a notion of mechanism
complexity again for families of
mechanisms
based on covering numbers from machine
learning and so that's really drawn from
the same circle of ideas as the measure
i'm going to tell you about
pseudo-dimension
it's not technically the same but it's
sort of drawn from the same area of
machine learning
and here are the main differences you
know they did this work basically about
10 years ago
when prior free mechanism design was all
the rage so this is where you don't even
you don't even assume there's an unknown
distribution you just assume there's no
distribution
you want a worst case guarantee and so
here you even have to figure out like
what are you shooting for like what's
the benchmark
so they solve all these problems they
propose the benchmarks they get
mechanisms competitive with these
benchmarks
but because of the demanding prior free
setting they're not going to be able to
cover the same
range of environments that we will when
we do assume unknown distributions
for example single item auctions are not
covered by the theory and that's
certainly one thing i want to i want to
be able to reason about today
okay so what is the measure so the
measure is actually not a new measure
it's been around since the 80s
from statistical learning theory it's
called the pseudo-dimension
i'll give you a formal definition in a
couple slides i'm not going to give it
to you now for a couple reasons first of
all i mean when i think about what i
want you to take away from the talk i
more want you to remember what this does
for you
like what are the implications and
applications of this definition than the
definition itself
secondly you know if you know vc
dimension
then you know this okay and that'll be
clear when i give you the definition it
was just really sort of a
adaptation of vc dimension from binary
to real valued functions okay
but the point is for the moment take it
on faith that i will associate a number
to every set c of mechanisms okay and c
here might be infinite think of c
is like you know vcg again with all
possible choices of bitter specific
reserves something like that
so why should you care about this
definition okay well the first reason is
conceptual
which is that it really seems to kind of
capture the intuitive notion of how
simple or complex the ex in the
mechanisms and the motivating examples
are
so for example maybe let's just think
about single item auctions for a second
suppose you just take like the second
price auction with all choices of an
anonymous reserve
okay it feels like one degree of freedom
and indeed that family of mechanisms
will have constant pseudo-dimension
how about with bitter specific reserves
again just say like a second second item
option with better specific reserves
well now you have n degrees of freedom
and again the pseudo dimension is
growing basically linear and n
it's totally possible this log factor is
just an artifact of our proof okay but
it's certainly
uh ballpark n how about back
to the single buyer case so the bobby
ethanol mechanism which has one
possibility
either does the grand bundle or sells
atom separately well there you can prove
that the pseudo-dimension is
growing basically linearly in k as you'd
sort of expect with the degrees of
freedom argument okay so in contrast to
the menu complexity here which is
exponential virtual welfare maximizes on
the other hand even in a single item
auction
that doesn't have finite pseudo
dimension at all okay sort of again
mirroring our intuition that they're in
infinite degrees of freedom because
you're because you have a full choice of
the virtual evaluation function
okay so it seems to give on you know
insanity check examples it seems to give
you kind of very sensible
uh sensible results the second reason to
care
is that again there are implications so
if your family of mechanisms is simple
in this sense
then you automatically get good sample
complexity properties
so let me talk a little bit about
learning mechanisms from data
so jason talked a little bit about this
in his talk but let me just review to
you the whole model
so again this is a non-new result this
has been sort of a you know
bedrock result statistical learning
theory which says low super dimension is
a sufficient condition for low sample
complexity
so what do i mean by that what do i mean
by sample complexity well it's a
standard pack learning type model if
that's something you're familiar with
but the basic idea is you observe you
posit that there's an unknown
distribution okay over valuations okay
you don't know what it is
but you positive exists and that's where
bidders are coming from okay
you assume you have data in the form of
samples from this distribution okay so
you know about this distribution only in
as much
as you have s iid samples okay
you can think of this you know in
practice you can think of this as you
know bid data from past auctions
ignoring incentive issues if you have
repeated bidders in these auctions okay
and indeed there is a field study on
sponsored search auctions at yahoo where
more or less maps pretty directly to
this kind of way of reasoning about
auction design
anyway so you don't know the
distribution if you knew the
distribution you just run the optimal
mechanism like myosin's mechanism
so as a function of the samples only you
have to figure out what mechanism you're
going to run
tomorrow for a fresh set of bitters
drawn from this exact these exact same
populations okay with
evaluations drawn in the identical way
how do we evaluate the quality of your
mechanism but whatever you pick we just
draw a new valuation profile from the
unknown distributions and we look at the
revenue you get
okay and so basically you want to have a
smart function for choosing this
mechanism
so that the revenue you get on a random
draw is almost as good as the optimal
mechanism almost as good as if you knew
not only samples
but the full distribution okay and then
the sample complexity is just saying
how big does s need to get before you're
guaranteed with high probability to be
able to compute a mechanism m which is
almost
as good as the optimal mechanism okay so
that's the sample complexity
all right so this is really starting to
explode which
is cool it's a really great topic
beginning with a paper again way ahead
of its time by by edith i think is in
the audience somewhere
so there's a lot of people working on
this there's a lot of exciting stuff to
do which is really cool
um so let me actually go now actually
tell you what is the implication
okay so now that hopefully maybe you
think it's a reasonable problem to want
to learn an auction
that's optimal for an unknown
distribution what do you actually get
from low pseudo dimension
so if the center dimension is d okay so
this is like corresponds to the one or n
log n
or k log k that's what d was a couple
slides ago
uh then the sample complexity is scaling
linearly with d okay so it also has
quadratic dependence on one over epsilon
squared which shouldn't surprise you
there's different versions of this
statement i'm going to state the version
where you have bounded valuations
between 0 and
h and you want additive error epsilon
and so then it's also going to be
scaling quadratic in h okay the the
bound on the maximum possible evaluation
so again so the point is that low pseudo
dimension is a sufficient condition for
low
sample complexity okay so if d is small
if d is polynomial on the relevant
parameters
then this is also polynomial relevant
parameters okay so at least modulo
capital h
good so what's the guarantee what's the
formal guarantee so what's the learning
algorithm the learning algorithm is the
trivial one often goes by empirical risk
minimization
so you just draw this many samples you
just look at every single auction in
your class
you look at which one does the best on
the data and you just pick that one
okay so you literally just use the
training data optimized for it and then
use that
in the future for test data and that's
the mechanism for which this guarantee
will hold so with high probability
over the samples the mechanism which is
best on the training data will be within
one will be within epsilon
uh on on future future samples okay
so this is the sense in which if it's
simple and having low pseudo dimension
you automatically get
low sample complexity
um vi is a valuation profile
so should i think of it as a vector or
as a function
of the vector okay so
like in a single parameter setting this
would be an n vector with one valuation
per bitter
so that's editor evaluation oh it
doesn't matter
so for this for this is totally agnostic
i mean i mean this is really just if you
ever have a mechanism
class with little pseudo dimension this
will be true
questions okay uh so in this general
learning setting
the student dimension doesn't
characterize learnability
so to what extent is it you know it's
sufficient for you
that's an excellent question that's
still um largely
open um what they're what you know what
you can
say for some of the so some of the
dependencies i stage i state to you will
be optimal up to log factors
uh because there's a separate paper with
richard cole where we prove a linear
lower bound on sample complexity
and so since you know and then it sort
of matches our suited dimension upper
bound
i suspect it should be close to a
characterization like say up to log
factors in most cases that we care about
but that's sort of a conjecture at this
point yeah i think it's probably pretty
tight though that's my intuition
good okay so if you're simple in this
sense you get low sample complexity good
so what so i i do feel like i i do owe
you the definition
so um so there's two slides that are a
little technical and so so my goal for
these two slides is the following
if you sort of know vc dimension then my
goal is for you to actually understand
the two slides
more or less okay because just as a
delta from vc dimension because it's
really a very small delta
if you've never seen vc dimension then
you know i just want to
you know if you're very quick then you
might get this also but it's going to be
it's going to be brief so um but these
two slides if you don't understand them
it shouldn't impact your ability to
appreciate the rest of the talk
at all right so you can just take this
definition on faith and then you know
it's analytically tractable and it gives
you good stuff okay
all right so uh so the twist with vc
dimension is
sort of an extra quantifier which
involves choosing thresholds so where do
these come from
so vc dimension is about binary
functions okay
zero one functions on a domain okay
now so how should we think about an
auction here's what i want you to think
about an auction think of an auction as
a real valued function
okay what's the domain the domain is a
valuation profile
what's the output the output is just the
revenue that this particular mechanism
gets on this particular valuation
profile
all right so the domain is all possible
valuation profiles for a fixed mechanism
you get a
real valued function from valuation
profiles to revenue that mechanism okay
so but these are not binary functions
these are real valued functions
so how can we make them binary well kind
of the easy way to make a real value
function binary is you just set a
threshold
and you say well let's call it one if
it's above the threshold let's call it
zero if it's below the threshold
okay and that's it that's like the only
different difference consider to mention
a vc dimension
okay so formally you have to define a
notion of sets being shattered so this
is just like in vc dimension
so remember our domain is valuation
profiles so a subset is going to be
a collection of valuation profiles you
can think of this as like training data
if you want
which is some abstract set finite set
evaluation profiles
what does it mean to shatter this set it
means that there
is some way i can choose these
thresholds okay revenue targets if you
like t1 through ts so one revenue target
for each of the samples so that no
matter
how i label each sample as being either
above the threshold or below the
threshold
i can find a mechanism in this class
that matches the labeling okay so i
might pick a subset which says like
on samples one three and five i want you
to beat your revenue target on samples
two four and six
i want you to not i want you to be below
the revenue target and the claim is no
matter how i choose above and below
you can find a mechanism in this class
that matches my request
okay so it's measuring how expressive
sort of how you know
different the outcomes of these
mechanisms can look like as you range
across the class
all right so that's what it means to
shatter a subset and then the pseudo
dimension is going to be the largest
subset that you can shatter and
sometimes like with virtual welfare
maximizers you can actually shatter
arbitrarily large
subsets okay so that's the pseudo
dimension
now one you know even if you even if
this doesn't make any sense
one high level point i want you to take
away is that even though even if you
don't understand the definition now
i want you to have the sense that it's
actually analytically tractable to prove
bounds
on this measure for classes of
mechanisms that we care about
okay so i'm just going to show you a
slide with a proof sketch on the slide
and again if nothing else just realize
you know it's just some kind of
commentary arguments that everybody in
this room is perfectly capable of doing
it's really just not a hard thing
okay okay so let's go to as an example
single item auctions with bitter
specific reserves
okay so it's just single item second
price bitter specific reserves
the claim is that the pseudo dimension
is n log n and again i'm just going to
give you kind of i'm going to sort of
oversimplify this a little bit but this
should give you the gist
uh so what does it mean it means that
the only subsets you can shatter
are those with size n log n or less okay
that's what we're trying to prove
so pick your favorite subset okay s
suppose you shatter it let me argue that
s has to be small
okay so the way we're going to do this
is we're going to think about ranging
over all
auctions of this form okay so we range
over all second price auctions all
choices of the bitter specific reserves
and we look at how many distinct
labelings we can possibly generate for
this set s
again what do we mean by labeling set
your favorite revenue thresholds
look at look at whether this mechanism
is above or below the threshold
that gives me a binary labeling of the
sample okay so i range over all possible
mechanisms
each mechanism gives me one labeling
maybe a bunch of different mechanisms
give me the same labeling but i look at
the number of distinct labelings that i
get ranging over all mechanisms
what does it mean to shatter this set it
means i get all possible two to the s
labelings
okay so i'm going to upper bound the
number of labelings that i can generate
over this mechanism class
okay because it's not a very rich class
so how do you do that you do that in two
steps
so in the first step i'm just going to
have equivalence classes of these
mechanisms so buckets if you will
so you've fixed your sample so what is
that that's really s samples each one is
a value is a profile of n valuations
right it's a single item option and
bitters so s it's like a
s by n matrix so i have s n numbers
and then you have n degrees of freedom
you can choose your n reserves okay so
first i just look at an equivalence
class
where the relative ordering of your
choice of n reserves is the same
okay so the way it's interspersed
throughout these sm numbers in the
sample
is the same in all classes of some
auction within
one of these equivalence classes the
allocation rule is fixed right because
some of the relative order of the
reserves and the valuations are the same
you know a second price auction with
reserves it only uses comparisons in its
allocation rule so once i fixed the
relative ordering of everything i fixed
the allocation rule now as you vary
even holding the allocation rule fixed
as you vary uh so by allocation will i
mean the winner okay
and uh as you vary the reserve you do
change the revenue but it's in sort of
like a very simple way right so like if
you have two different auctions and
everything's the same except the revenue
is epsilon different
obviously you know it's changing in a
very benign way the difference between
these two mechanisms
so how many equivalence classes do you
have that's just sort of all different
ways of inserting n numbers into sn
numbers so
that's n as a raise to the n uh and then
you can just do a different counting
argument which again gives you some
exponential and
n only number of labelings per
equivalence class
okay so summarizing what are the key
features of this
so the number of labelings is the
product of two different things
each of which only has an n in the
exponent
the important part is that neither of
these numbers has an s
in the exponent why is that important
how do we shatter a subset you need all
possible labels you need two to the s
labelings
okay so if the number of labelings is
not growing exponentially in s
but the requirement for shattering is
growing exponentially in s there's going
to be some limit s
which you can't shatter anymore okay and
it's going to be n log n if you solve
for it
about uh randomized mechanisms yeah so
for randomized mechanisms
uh in some sense if you ignore i mean
basically
um what's your way to say this so
anyway i mean it's possible to extend
the argument i guess you have to do some
more work but
um good yeah
okay so again the point of that was just
you know
it's not trivial but it's analytically
tractable to bound the pseudo dimension
in cases of interest
in fact the argument i just gave you i
really used very little about a single
item option
that n log n bound continues to hold
even for you know our pretty much
arbitrary binary single parameter
environments
for the vic for the vcg mechanism with
bitter specific reserves
so what's the takeaway from this
so again what we hoped for for a
simplicity measure at the very beginning
is i said you want to automatically get
other stuff for free
basically so there's this there's this
part of the literature which i'm a huge
fan of where you design
simple mechanisms subjectively speaking
and you prove approximation guarantees
and the way one thinks about these is
you know you think that you think as if
you know what the distributions are but
you're only going to use like a little
bit about them you only use monopoly
prices for example
okay and so what this meta theorem says
is that you know actually simple
mechanisms in the sense that we've been
using it
actually you don't even need known
distributions okay it even works with
unknown distributions and a polynomial
number of samples
for example consider the bobby f at all
simple versus optimal mechanism what
does it say
it basically takes as input the
distributions it figures out the
relevant monopoly prices and takes the
better of two things
okay that's what it returns okay so that
sort of known distributions output a
simple mechanism
because that class has low pseudo
dimension again only scaling linearly in
k
from a poly and k number of samples you
can do exactly the same thing because
you can get exactly the same
7.5 approximation or six that aviod
proved
up to an epsilon even though you didn't
know the distributions at all even
though you only had poly and k samples
from those distributions
so the way to think about it is the
simple versus optimal results that the
community has been proving
they don't really need known
distributions they work fine if you just
have samples
okay okay
so let me just finish with one last
point
so you know i said at the beginning that
one reason you might want a concrete
simplicity measure so you can actually
really reason about simplicity versus
optimality trade-offs okay
and again we know how to measure
approximate optimality just use the
approximation guarantee
now you can use pseudo-dimension to
measure the simplicity of the class
so if we return to the first simple
versus optimal theorem i stated
that vcg with monopoly reserves is a two
approximation to the optimal
and this factor two is tight you might
say okay can we somehow gradually
increase the complexity of our mechanism
class
and then gradually get closer to full
optimality is there a nice interpolation
between vcg with monopoly reserves and
the full-blown myosin optimal mechanism
and so there is and you can use the
pseudo-dimension to
you know reason about exactly what kind
of trade-offs you can get
so the claim this is there's not a claim
that this is the unique way to do this
but this is a way you can do this
so to make vcg with reserves more
complicated
i'm going to allow you to set t reserves
per bitter okay
t here's a parameter okay so obviously
the bigger this is the bigger your
mechanism space
what's the meaning of having multiple
reserves let's just say it's a single
item auction okay although
it extends to other settings who's going
to be the winner
the winner is going to be the bidder
that clears the maximum number
of their reserves okay so if you said 10
reserves for every bidder
and there's some bidder that clears
eight of them and everyone else clears
seven or less
that one cleared eight is the winner
okay
if there's a tie you break ties by value
say okay
so that's a t level auction and so the
number of degrees of freedom right is
clearly growing as n times t
right you have t choices of a price for
each of the bidders
so how well does this do well it's it's
easy to extend the previous arguments
about the pseudo dimension
now it's growing linearly on n and t get
up to a log factor
and so then the question is okay so
suppose you set a revenue target of one
minus epsilon
and you ask what kind of uh you know
complexity is required to get this
well if you restricted t level auctions
then you can figure out that the value
of t
you need is you know something like h
over epsilon okay that's for metroids
for downward close environments it's
more like
hn squared over epsilon but the point is
it's polynomial on the relevant
parameters
okay so given an approximation guarantee
this basically gives you advice about
how many reserve prices t and therefore
how much complexity you need
in order to achieve that guarantee so
amount of times are just wrapping up so
what i'm proposing is not a new
definition it's actually an old
definition
of pseudo-dimension from statistical
learning theory
viewing mechanisms as real valued
functions you can literally just apply
this definition without change
to families of mechanisms a priori is
that a good idea
not clear but i hope to convince you
through a number of examples that it
seems to
give us what we want it seems to give us
intuitively quantify the number of
degrees of freedom in a mechanism design
space in a way the previous parameters
have not
despite the fact the definition you know
has a bunch of alternating quantifiers
for most of the settings that we study
the families of mechanisms that we care
about it's tractable to prove upper
bounds on this
and with a good upper bound you get
automatic sample complexity results
therefore sort of automatically
extending simple versus optimal
results from known distributions to
samples from an unknown distribution
i want to be clear at no point in this
talk did i discuss the computational
complexity so for example the running
time of these learning algorithms based
on empirical risk minimization
i think this is a wide open area where i
think there's lots of opportunities
for good research so let me stop there
thanks
uh about gabriel so i guess i started
at the beginning of the talk talking
talking about sort of informal
informal concept there's a number of
degrees of freedom in a mechanism family
and this is a way to formalize that are
there
uh are there any examples i should think
of that would
distinguish the formal concept of
pseudo-dimension from what
from what i might sort of vaguely think
of a number of degrees of freedom
yeah but i do think it's a little more
general um
yeah there's sort of a i think it's fine
as a mental model to have a rough
equivalence i mean
but for example if you have a finite set
then the pseudo dimension is going to be
a log of the cardinality and it's not
clear how to define degrees of freedom
and there's other there's other examples
like that there's also like
hard to describe classes of finite vc
dimension that are just
actually crazy sure so in particular any
fixed mechanism
has pseudo-dimension one okay so
uh in the sense that you could define
you could find there are classes of sets
that have
a low vc dimension but each of those
sets is very hard to describe
so so you you could have something i
mean
you're picking up something that could
be orthogonal to simplicity
yeah yeah i mean there's i'm certainly
there's no claim that this is
the only relevant definition i'm just
trying to claim this is a relevant
definition
if you're convinced of that i'll be
happy kevin so
you've got these real valued functions
that go from values to revenues
presumably you could you could do it
with welfare as well right
i mean when you're talking about
simplicity um
you're trying to appeal to something
intuitive from our perspective but the
mechanism not
something to do with with ultimate
revenue of the mechanism of gas
i mean what what does that mean about
the the claim that this has to do with
simplicity
and and what other concepts maybe
besides welfare would also make sense
yeah so i mean for the first question i
mean kind of any objective function
is fine now it might factor in
to the pseudo-dimension calculation so
when we actually do the pseudo dimension
upper bound
um you know we do sort of work with the
revenue
uh formula um but sort of the the
general thing about pseudo-dimension
gives you low sample complexity
that's sort of independent of the choice
of the functions so you're sort of right
that it's it's measuring it's kind of
it's i mean it's it's not really about
the mechanism itself and more about the
behavior of the mechanism
as filtered through you know some
summary statistic
um and so you know the natural one is
whatever objective function you care
about but
you could do something else so you know
obviously if you have uh
so in some sense you could have
mechanisms which seem complicated if you
just wrote down the description
and yet somehow it's very well behaved
with respect to your objective
and you're going to get a little
pseudo-dimension and that may or may not
be a good thing sort of depending on
what you're trying to capture
yeah like i wonder could you even do
something maybe this is a terrible idea
but could you even do something like you
know
welfare up to a factor of the best
welfare or something and you get a price
of anarchy kind of simplicity here
is it possible to have something that's
you know more um
more sort of processed than uh sure
sure i mean you can you i mean you could
i mean because right you take as input
evaluation profile so at that point the
welfare is well defined and you can look
at the welfare so if you want you can
find the real value function as the
approximation
and then you'll be looking at some kind
of expected approximation factor
over your domain so it's very agnostic
to what these functions look like
but as you say i mean if you choose
certain functions it may hide
certain things we think of as complexity
which just don't show up because of the
function that we chose
so your initial motivation was that well
it's easier to learn
some numbers but it's very difficult to
learn a function because it's infinite
dimensional
but in practice we can approximate just
like your last result you can
approximate the punch pretty well for
our purposes
and get almost the same result as we
wanted so
then why couldn't you just approximate
the optimal
myosin asymmetric mechanism by learning
these distributions
with some approximation in the in the
same speed
as you would just learn you can and i
think actually for the computational
complexity results that's probably the
way to go
um but sort of the point is i mean so
what comes out of this just the sample
complexities you don't always need to
learn a lot about the distributions just
to actually make the right decision
right so so the usual way you go through
empirical revenue
uh maximization you know so you know
like in some of some of your early work
is you actually kind of estimate the
distributions directly
and then you run an optimal economy with
respect to the learned distributions
this doesn't require
right so you're not you're not
responsible for outputting say like a
you know good approximation under some
norm of the real distributions you're
just responsible for outputting
the best mechanism with respect to your
objective so that can lead to better
sample complexity results it certainly
leads to simpler algorithms
but i think for computational efficiency
we'll probably have to go the route that
you're suggesting